addicted
to youtube videos about people uh
near-death experiences and like
experiences their experiences would
happen when they die
and i've been fascinated with that and
it's it's weird because
in the near death experience is sort of
community and
and all of these people telling their
stories about it there's a lot of common
ground man you know you really like
there's a lot that adds up and it
becomes credible
because everyone's describing the same
thing i've never heard about the
watching people [ __ ] part
but like i've heard about like um
they talk about a spirit guide you know
comes and
and you feel compelled that you want to
like uh go with it go and go with your
family they say go with your spirit
guide you know
like go and go with your spirit guide
it's also really fascinating how
like the life review yeah the life of
your dude where
you can like i mean dude there's like
are we are we uh
agreed that life review is like we
we can just call that a fact because
like that all of the accounts of it are
all so like
well have you ever had like uh have you
guys ever had like a life review
in the drug experience where you go
through like different situations
because like in the in the near death
experience people have these life
reviews
and they're like feeling how they
the person felt that you talk [ __ ] to
you like everything but but
i want to bring that up because like um
i'm so fascinated with your fascination
with life reviews
like dude life review is the most
crucial thing if anybody hasn't heard
this term you can look it up what it is
is that like at the at the moment of
death
like you know they say it in rock songs
or whatever poems like your life flashes
before your eyes
now that's saying about your when you
die your life flashes before your eyes
like the as it's described in people who
have had the experience and that like
died had their life review and then come
back and and like yeah they're
completely changed because they're like
[ __ ] i've caused that much
damage you experience your entire life
like you could say
your life flashes before your eyes it
happens in a moment but it also happens
in super slow-mo like time's just not
even
you you you re-experience your entire
life
in this flash with like super
consciousness like the consciousness of
of like the like the whole like
basically god if even if you don't like
that term
but like you go through your whole life
and
you personally experience from the
perspective of
every thing that you had an influence
over
and with the detail of that if there is
a mosquito
like off like uh you know
further than the eye can see like you
have the experience of being that
mosquito like
the idea of oneness becomes an
experience
where you actually like you're no longer
separated so you
you review your whole life and you and
it's not
for the purpose of punishing you for
like the harm that you've done to others
it's just for for the experience so it
becomes real like oh my god
and the the common denominator in having
this life review
is that everybody who comes back to
being human everyone who comes back
to life now they are so overwhelmingly
concerned
with not [ __ ] over other people they
are no longer concerned with material
things like they are like
totally changed and in such a way and
like
i've seen so many like uh just been so
fascinated with this life if you
think that i've like to think i don't
even need to have a life review to just
trust that that's the truth and just do
not [ __ ] with other people
be generous well it's crazy you know
like yeah it's crazy because the two
common denominators that people have i
mean like thousands and thousands of
people
like 90 of them come back and get a
divorce and then the other ones come
back and
and they can't wear watches because
watches don't work
what yeah i never heard them
because it always breaks holy [ __ ] we've
added another
[ __ ] part of the roller coaster
we're talking about in the beginning
like before the divorce we
put him under like we kill him and then
bring him back to life
i mean dude like there's a really good
example of a guy who had a near-death
experience and there's a documentary
about it
is that the one called i am but um the
dude who
who directed all the like just
monstrously successful jim carrey movies
uh tom shadiak yeah yeah this guy
was like private jets like [ __ ] look
at my
[ __ ] huge mansion this guy was just
so tens of millions
of dollars for like every movie he was
just cranking him out so he just had
obnoxious amounts of money then at some
point he was riding uh
his bicycle had like a hellacious
wipeout riding his bicycle and
and in that wipeout like had like where
he
like he died had the near-death
experience came back from it
and the dude ever since
i gave every i don't know if he gave
everything away but like
lives in a [ __ ] trailer in a trailer
park in malibu like just doesn't
has no [ __ ] interest whatsoever in uh
like the lifestyle that he had like he's
a good example of like
how near-death experiences like uh
change people
you know and i volunteered at a hospice
called rose room hospice in
la for a little bit and the guy who was
like came to tell us how to like be with
dying people
he was one of those people he had a [ __ ]
ton of money
he [ __ ] died he went the whole thing
the life review the whole thing didn't
want to come back
didn't that's the other commonality no
thanks i'm done it's like no you're not
done
you're going back and you go back and
you and like um
it's painful going back into the body
yes
well he what he said is what's over
there makes this
where we're at seem like death compared
to that other place like we're
in a he i think he called it a warp
like he said we're in a time warp when
you're alive and the other side
is so wonderful it's more of the spa
theory of things
i hope that's the case i really do i i
want that to be the
the the reality versus like the other
versions of it
which have justice built into them you
know a kind of like
like mathematical justice and maybe the
life review is enough maybe if you do
the life review yeah
and and and that is the penance is like
experiencing the
right way that you make everyone feel
yeah yeah and that's all you need that's
the purification or something
but um yeah i don't i mean it's it's so
mysterious but i do
think it's like pretty incredible the
way that regardless of culture
regardless of what your religious
background is you're going to have the
same experience when you die that's one
of the things the
nde experts talk about is it's like it
doesn't matter if you're hindu
jewish whatever it may be the that's the
life review
it's the light it's all the things that
you hear about and it seems to transcend
culture
which is another implication that you
know it's uh
it's something real or if not real the
cynical
version of it as well it's a something
built into us it's crazy like you hear
like a life
or like a near-death experience story of
um like a 60 year old woman that goes to
church every day you know and
she she dies and comes back and they're
like well are you still a christian
she's like
no not at all like it has nothing to do
with that you know and then
you know just hearing hearing that from
that perspective you're like [ __ ] man
like there's something out there you
know yeah i mean it's more there's
something
in here you know like the the idea of
space and time is just
such an illusion um but but yeah yeah
the
the the documentary that i did the whole
thing was like i went to india to go
meditate to go find like this thing i'm
seeking and like
i read this thing from emerson that said
the nate quasi varus extra
and and it doesn't really tell you what
that is and i looked it up and it was uh
it's latin for do not seek outside
yourself and i just had that
it's like you didn't have to go 15 000
miles to india to find any answers like
you can just do it from
the wild ride van you know or just kind
of sure well that's the classic
archetype like you had it in you all
along you know like uh
we're drawn to those kinds of stories
yeah yeah
it's also like we can't have this
spiritual [ __ ] tourism right now i
mean it's like
to me like the ironic thing about
spiritual tourism when you're doing the
thing you get in the plane you fly to
wherever you think the holy people
are going to the amazon to take
ayahuasca is like as you're flying over
the amazon you're just like dumping
jet fuel on top of the place where
you're gonna go after spiritual
experience that's so funny
so we yeah i think that's a a real great
epiphany you're at because uh
it's it just i especially these days i
don't know that i think there's some
there's a bit of an illusion
in all of that that being said if
ramadas didn't
go to india with a bunch of acid i think
i wouldn't be as happy a person now
because he you know because of his
experiences there but maybe the idea is
they already did that so now we don't
have we don't have to do it you know we
the data's out there right we're ready
for you
if you want to sort of you know pick up
some path or discipline
can i just tell you how [ __ ] up my new
tour is
it's completely multimedia legitimately
x-rated
there's legal waivers all over the venue
because i'm actually worried about
getting sued
and i don't give a [ __ ] man because it's
gnarly and
it's all the stuff i wasn't allowed to
do on jackass
so get to my [ __ ] website stevo.com
and get your tickets man especially with
this movie coming out dude
they're all gonna sell dude so hurry up
while you can get seats